let's take it back inside how did this
all begin gizmodo reported may 9th 2016
former far-right gizmodo far right
former facebook workers we routinely
suppressed conservative news
and when i said wow look at this report
from
what is news guard certified
real news
i get accused of echoing false claims
from conservatives that they routinely
face suppression and censorship and then
every time that comes up i'm like oh
i've never asserted that as a fact i've
only cited gizmodo now of course it's a
fact we have ample evidence it's
happening but the crazy thing is
when the news broke it was gizmodo that
was telling conservatives they were
being suppressed all of a sudden now the
narrative shifts i mean look at their
image it's an elephant with a sheet over
it
gizmodo of all outlets
we know it's happening
i think vijaya gaday may have been
crying at our twitter meeting because
they were doing something unethical
immoral or potentially illegal
and they're about to get caught
i think
that monday night
when twitter learned that so this is
what make this this makes more sense a
lot of people are saying progressives
are leaving conservatives are joining it
is true to a certain degree that many
conservatives are tweeting like look i
just signed up sure unit makes more
sense
when the twitter staff had that all
hands-on meeting later in the day
and the ceo said it's happening
let me answer your questions
after that meeting which is now 5 p.m
it's probably 6 7 p.m eastern someone
there said clean it up clean it up clean
it up man you got to get rid of all that
code
he's gonna come in he's gonna see this
we are going to jail dude and then
pulled the code out and that night boom
josie gets reinstated
all of these learn to code people start
getting reinstated i think they were
running an algorithmic ban on
right-leaning uh users for saying things
like learn to code i bet there was a
list of phrases that yeah that wasn't
the only obvious and overtly
right-leaning i bet you hundred biden's
in there or the 100 different laptop
story
and i think we all know the
pharmaceutical industry there's many
many pharmaceutical interests and topics
that were controlled charles does the
pharmaceutical industry have influence
on the media what are you saying what
guys who is this
but i think that's another big one
that's at play jack that's completely
not true let me just quickly say um this
episode is brought to you by pfizer
you see that meme where like every
show is brought to you we're not really
true though
i have to clarify that was a joke no
we're we're yes we're we're actually
brought to you by frieza
we're just kidding also cheryl can be
pretty sure she can beat us all up what
bothers me is that there's no way to
well at this stage there's no way to
know if there's nefarious stuff going on
in the twitter code i wish that i wish
that we could watch that happen it's
another value of having the software be
free keep in mind they went ahead and
changed stuff really fast is it too late
now did they make changes that even if
someone were to go in and try to see is
it too late look i i said this yesterday
on on war room and i'll say it here
again elon musk didn't just buy a
platform elon musk bought evidence he's
got all this and i guarantee you that he
knows people that he can bring in that
when they actually peel back the curtain
uh look under the hood of this thing
they can go back as far as they have to
go because he will bring in the highest
caliber people because you see all the
stories by the way in business insider
they say oh he's you know he's so
demanding and he's always firing people
no because he wants the best
can i say something if he's really smart
and i think he's really smart
these transactions as you know
they're gone over by attorneys and
analysts
some attorney from elon musk's group
sent some attorneys over at twitter a
note that said don't touch them preserve
your records
preserve your records but
watch out for twitter going down
mysteriously yep which of course happens
watch for any kind of server migration
so right now if they manipulate code
i believe it it's theoretically possible
to see that they've done changes to look
at edits but uh correctly if i'm wrong
and if they migrate the servers fresh
copy only the existing code all the
records are going to be lost
i don't think i'm qualified to answer
that i don't know
so can i can i just go back real quick
on to the the ministry of truth by the
way because i've just got well let's i
want to bring the story up right now
okay because there's an update and oh my
goodness let me pull up this story first
and we'll throw it to jack we have this
from timcast.com department of homeland
security forms disinformation governance
board homeland security secretary
alejandro mayorka said the board would
work to prevent disinformation campaigns
that target minority groups
they lost twitter and this quickly they
are already trying to play dirty games
we have it over at the daily mail where
they mention it is being head his
binders is a disinformation governance
board and it is being headed by a russia
expert who called the hunter laptop
story a trump campaign product and said
she shudders to think about elon musk
taking over twitter
well here's our ministry of truth jack
what's going on well tim see here's the
thing is that nina jankowicz of the
moaning myrtles has has has responded so
she's responded to some of this
criticism she notes for those who
believe this tweet is key to all my
views it is simply a direct quote from
both candidates for you see this was
during the final presidential campaign
and if you debate and if you look at my
timeline you will see i was live
tweeting this she was just live tweeting
she was just live during the debate
except here's the problem in the
immediate follow-up tweet to this she
wrote
the emails didn't need to be altered to
be part of an influence campaign voters
deserve the context again the keyword
context not a fairy tale about a laptop
repair shop
she called it an influence campaign in
the very next tweet so we caught her in
day one on the job lying about what she
said about the hunter biden laptop
trying to cover it up but i'm sorry nina
we got the receipts
can i say that i find it a little
odd
that we've all bought into arguing over
sort of the minutia of how this is done
instead of stepping back and looking at
2015
and the notion that anybody should
control for any reason so we're arguing
should they control a certain hashtag
does it really attack people mate wasn't
a tech
why are they controlling a hashtag in
the first place
before 2015 there was relatively little
if any discussion
over bringing in third parties a
corporation no less
to control the content that we can
access and make our own decisions on on
the internet
the social media companies had already
invented tools where we could control
our own experience if you don't want to
see something if you want someone to
call your experience you can follow the
right people you can block other people
the notion that someone else should be
doing that for us
was introduced to us in about 2016 and
we've kind of bought into we've argued
over the terms
we've kind of bought into that there are
reasons why this should be done and
there are people who could maybe do it
better instead of stepping back in my
view and saying
only that which is illegal should be
moderated by anybody in my view well
that's where we've been right so we had
i mean yes
on the show who said here's my rules and
he pulls out the constitution and i'm
like agreed well that's kind of what
elon's saying now that right that his
his notion and this this by the way this
is why these two stories are connected
because elon said that his view and he
said this in that ted talk he gave last
week or the it was actually an interview
i guess um that his notion should be
that it should be up to the laws of the
state in which twitter is operating
because those laws are reflect
reflective of the will of the people i
guess if you're in a democracy right um
that being said right that being said
the very same way the inc isn't even dry
on the paperwork for twitter and already
the bide administration is launching a
ministry of truth they know they've lost
this one
and they had such power in the private
sector because their sycophants were
just like but it's a private company
now that they've lost it because someone
had the money to buy it now it's going
government this will be interesting
you'll need you'll need money to combat
this in the courts it'll be difficult
does anybody read are they required to
read anymore
i'm a little older than you guys but
1984. of course yeah an animal farm in
school my kid wasn't
i mean we read it at home i don't think
i was required to no this was required
reading when when i was growing up wow
and when you say ministry of truth and i
get it a lot of people get it i think a
lot of people when i've mentioned these
things about 1984
and how language is used to mean the
exact opposite of what it really is by
the government all the things that are
happening
that are such perfect parallels to what
were written what were written about
decades ago
so many people seem unaware of and i
feel like if people had
been opened up to this they could see it
happening and witness it with some
knowledge that they're not able to in
many instances now right and the main
the main character for those who haven't
read it the main character of 1984 works
for the ministry of troops right that's
his job is to go back in time and censor
things that are no longer in line with
the party narrative the ministry of
peace is all about war the ministry of
love is all about
hatred or whatever they call it double
speak double speak yeah so we normally
save super chats for the end but
typically sometimes we get a good one we
do have a good one here from christopher
who said they're purging their code but
they're bringing back followers to make
their earnings report look good so elon
can't buy now i don't know if that's
true that he wouldn't be able to buy if
the earning report looks good but this
will affect the earnings report if
twitter comes out and says we had a
massive increase of users look at all
this
i think elon musk cornered twitter
he came to them knowing their earnings
report was going to be bad and the stock
would fall
and so they had no choice but to accept
the premium because he made the offer
only a couple weeks before they had to
do their earnings report
if they did not accept the 54 20 cents
earnings report comes out stock drops to
30 the board can be sued for that
massive loss by the shareholders who
would be outraged so he wins this one
they can't break the deal now if they do
they lose a billion dollars but it is
interesting because whatever twitter is
doing right now removing these bands
will make their growth look better
so someone that's not paying attention
right people that are like well i was
unbanned except the report will say in
quarter one we saw an influx of 3.4
million users they won't say it was the
last day that they unbanned everybody
yeah they're not going to talk about how
they got to be careful with fraud if
they're going to try and fraud it's not
fraud uh it's not defraud their
investors by telling them that a bunch
of accounts that they were they had
anyway that they were considering
unbanning before they just chose to do
it to make some extra money they're
going to go to prison that's why
that's why they're running around to
everyone in the media saying oh no no
this is organic of course that's why
they're making sure to give statements
every single day to everyone
getting a band is not organic that was
something right and they in my opinion
lied to congress
when they're like there's there's
nothing in place for censoring these
people or politics it's like bro your
rules outright say misgendering will get
you banned
but it's an inversion of how
conservatives see what misgendering is
their rules are overtly targeting
conservatives and they are lying to
congress about it and they're not
getting in trouble i'm looking at the
top 10 owners of twitter it's vanguard
morgan stanley blackrock ssga funds
management aristotle capital management
fidelity management clearbridge
investments it's 10 investment firms do
you know what ssga is
uh no
stupid ssga funds management yeah you're
gonna you're gonna love this wow
yeah look it up what does the ssga stand
on state street isn't it
state street globalization global so
state street's number four yep so they
don't care about line they're going to
send jack dorsey up there make him tell
him to lie to congress and then he's
going to be the one that's on the hook
but here's something goes wrong but
listen what happens is they give
themselves plausible deniability
they go to jack and say hey jack here's
the report on everything we're doing and
he goes okay then he goes to congress
and they're like are you doing this we
are not doing the based on a report he
read that was a lie to him and then he
says well they lied to me i didn't know
i told the truth
and the person who lied to me wasn't
under oath
that's the game that's a tough one how
do you how do you navigate that kind of
situation are they claiming really high
paid lawyers yup
that's how you know are they claiming
net gains of users because they're also
people claiming they're fleeing twitter
but are they saying that overall they're
gaining way more than they're supposed
to be that's that's the strategy that's
what tim's saying is that the strategy
is they can pick up and far surpass
by removing the bands so it's not even a
political thing in this in this theory
it's just it's about the earnings katy
perry lost 200 000 followers
you're not going to convince me that a
bunch of katy perry fans were like i am
outraged that you learned about the
platform they might she also lost
russell brand more importantly she also
that's sad oh really yeah i mean if
anyone's gonna like annoyingly just
leave out of emotion it would be someone
that follows katie no offense kate but
you know your fans are like well didn't
bubblegum barack obama lose you know
hundreds of thousands everybody knows
that those main accounts and elon dave
rubin had the tweet up today
that the new york times has 53 million
followers and yet gets like 50 retweets
per tweet and elon musk even responded
to that saying what's going on actually
reuben used to talk about this all the
time you call it the reuben ratio right
so the reuben ratio is how many
followers you have versus what is your
engagement meanwhile like you know i can
write something in a certain way
you know or drop receipts on someone
like we just did because government
official nina jankowicz um catching her
in a provable lie in a demonstrable lie
and that's going to get tons of retweets
but a new york times article with 53 you
know one percent of that right should be
enough to get didn't he say he could
tweet a celebrity photo and a banana and
it would get more tweaked see i wasn't
gonna bring that up cheryl and it did he
did and it got it was like an 80s sitcom
and a banana and he got more he got like
5000 retweets thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there